MARTINA BALAGOVIC: Hi.
Welcome to recitation.
Today's problem is
about change of basis.
It says the vector
space of polynomials
in x of degree up to 2 has
a basis 1, x, and x squared.
That's the obvious
basis that you would
write for that vector space.
But today we're going to
consider another basis, w_1,
w_2, and w_3.
And we don't know what w_1,
w_2, and w_3 are explicitly.
What we know is that
their values at x
equals minus 1, 0, and 1 are
given by this table here.
So they are 1, 0, 0;
0, 1, 0; and 0, 0, 1.
We're asked to do the following.
We're asked to express
this polynomial-- so y
of x is minus x plus 5-- in
this basis, w_1, w_2, w_3.
We're asked to find
the change of basis
matrices between these two
bases, 1, x, x squared,
and w_1, w_2, w_3.
And finally, we're asked to
find the matrix of taking
derivatives, which is a
linear map on this space,
in both of these basis.
And let me give you an extra
level of challenge, which
is to try to do as much of this
as possible without explicitly
finding w_1, w_2, and w_3.
I'll let you think
about the problem
and then you can come back
and compare your solution
with mine.
Hi.
Welcome back.
So to start with
the problem a, we
need to find coefficients alpha,
beta, and gamma so that y of x
is expressed through,
with this coefficient,
in this new basis,
w_1, w_2, and w_3.
now, one way to do
that would be to look
at this table of
values, explicitly
find w_1, w_2, and w_3, so
a quadratic polynomial is--
all the information
we need about it
is in values at three points.
So say w_1 is a*1 plus b times
x plus c times x squared.
Find a, b, and c.
Find w_1, w_2, w_3 explicitly,
and then go back to this system
and try to find
alpha, beta and gamma.
However, there's a trick.
Let's try to see if we
can do it without finding
w_1, w_2, and w_3 explicitly.
So let me try to see
what are the values of y
at these points.
So y is minus x plus 5.
So the values are 6, 5, and 4.
And let me, instead of
considering this equation,
let me evaluate it at x is
minus 1, x is 0, and x is 1.
What I get through this is
that w at minus 1-- actually,
let me write this.
I get w at minus 1,
which is a number,
equals alpha times
w_1 at minus 1,
which is a number, plus
beta times w_2 at minus 1,
plus gamma times w_3 at minus 1.
And similarly at 0,
and similarly at 1.
And now, let me think of
this as a linear system that
has unknowns alpha,
beta, and gamma
coefficients, these values
here at minus 1, 0, and 1.
And the right-hand
side, well, what's
written here on the left-hand
side. y at minus 1, y at 0,
and y at 1.
If you write this in a matrix
and read off coefficients
from there, you get
the following system.
So this is the matrix of the
system read off from here.
These are the unknowns.
And these are the values
of the right-hand side.
And I hope you'll agree that
this is a very easy system
to solve.
We just get alpha is 6,
beta is 5, and gamma is 4.
So the solution to the first
part is y equals 6*w_1 plus
5*w_2 plus 4*w_3.
And let's notice another thing.
No matter what
values we put here,
this matrix is always
going to stay the same.
It's only the right-hand
side that's going to change.
So if we're given
any other polynomial
now to express in a
basis w_1, w_2, and w_3,
we don't have to
do any thinking.
We don't have to do
any computations.
What we do is go back to
our table at the beginning
and just read off-- let's
go back to the table,
and just read these values.
So in this case, y is 6
times w_1, 5 times w_2,
and 3 times w_3.
And that's already
a hint to solving
the b part, which is
find the change of basis
matrices between 1, x, x
squared and w_1, w_2, w_3.
Change of basis matrices
means expressing
one basis in terms of another.
So as a part of the
problem, we will
have to express 1,
x, and x squared
in terms of w_1, w_2, w_3.
So let's just find their
values at these three points.
One is a constant, it just
takes value 1 everywhere.
x takes value minus 1 at
minus 1, 0 at 0, and 1 at 1.
And x squared takes values 1,
0, and 1 at minus 1, 0, and 1.
And from this we can already
conclude the part b here,
we can conclude that 1
equals w_1 plus w_2 plus w_3.
That x equals
minus w_1 plus w_3.
And that x squared
equals w_1 plus w_3.
And from this, we
can immediately
write one change
of basis matrix.
Namely, since we know
how to express 1, x,
and x squared in terms
of w_1, w_2, and w_3,
we can just copy
this information over
to this matrix, getting 1, 1,
1; minus 1, 0, 1; and 1, 0, 1.
So which matrix is this?
This is a matrix--
so we have 1, x,
and x squared expressed in
terms of w_1, w_2, and w_3.
So if we feed this matrix
something expressed
in the basis 1, x, and
x squared, say a, b,
and c, what it's
going to throw out
is the same polynomial expressed
in this basis here, w_1, w_2,
and w_3.
So I'm going to just write that
this is a matrix of this basis
change.
How do we get the other one?
Well, very easy.
We know it's just
the inverse of A.
So this is going to
be the matrix that
takes something
written in this basis
and transfers it to this basis.
I'm not going to
calculate the inverse
of a matrix in front of you.
Instead I'm going to
consult my oracle.
Sorry about that.
And my oracle says
that the inverse
should be 0, 1, 0; minus 1/2,
0, 1/2; and 1/2, minus 1, 1/2.
And that solves the b part.
Let's go into the c part.
The c part required us to find
a matrix of taking derivatives,
which is a linear map in
the space of polynomials,
in both of these basis.
So let's first do the
1, x, x squared basis
because that one's easier.
I'm going to call it D_x.
So I'm going to work in
basis 1, x, x squared.
And what I want to express
is the transformation
of taking derivatives.
So here I'm going
to write the vector
to which taking derivatives maps
the polynomial 1, which is 0.
And that's this expressed in
the basis 1, x, x squared.
In the second column I'm
going to write x prime,
the vector to which
D_x sends to vector
x, and that's equal to 1,
which expressed in this basis
is 1, 0, 0.
And here I'm going
to write x squared
prime, which is 2x, which,
expressed in this basis,
is just this.
That one was easy.
For the other one,
well we could calculate
w_1, w_2, w_3 explicitly,
take the derivatives,
go back to the table
and repeat the procedure
that we did already.
So expressing these derivatives
in terms of w_1, w_2, w_3,
and that's a lot of work.
But we pretty much already
did most of this work.
So we know how to take
derivatives in this basis,
and we know how to go
between these two basis.
So if we want to take a
derivative of something written
in the basis w_1, w_2,
w_3, well, let's first
write this something in
basis 1, x, x squared.
Then let's take a
derivative of it.
And then let's write it
back in the original basis
that we want.
So it's multiplication
of three matrices.
We have all three-- matrix
multiplication is easy.
And my oracle, again, says
that this should be minus 3
over 2, 2, minus 1 over 2;
minus 1 over 2, 0, 1 over 2;
and 1 over 2, minus 2, 3 over 2.
And that solves the problem.
Now, one thing that I would
want to discuss in the end
is how did you do with
respect to my challenge, which
was let's try to do as
much of it as possible
without finding w_1,
w_2, and w_3 explicitly.
And it seems like
we did really well.
There's nowhere on the
board written w_1 equals,
w_2 equals, w_3 equals.
But is it really so?
It's not.
We calculated the matrix
of A inverse here.
And what this really means is
that w_1, w_2, and w_3, written
in the basis 1, x, and x
squared, are as follows.
w_1 is minus 1/2 x
plus 1/2 x squared.
w_2 is 1 minus x squared.
And w_3 is 1/2 x
plus 1/2 x squared.
So you can check your work
with the help of this matrix
in case you did find w_1,
w_2, and w_3 explicitly.
And that's all I
wanted to say today.